how many of you guys actually try
putting on lotion and it actually dries
your skin out does that happen to anyone
else all right guys let's talk about
eczema as you know I have eczema I made
a video about XML a while ago I was
really surprised at the feedback from
that video based on the comment section
I realized how many people actually have
X amount there and because of that video
a lot my friends told me the else of
eczema as I've seen in the comments a
lot of you guys share the same feelings
that I felt if you don't know what
excellent is it's a skin condition in
which your skin gets very dry very
easily it gets agitated easily gets
rashes skin flakes off gets really itchy
you want to scratch it a lot and when
you do scratch it it tends to get cut up
and open wounds start to form and bodily
fluids start to ooze out it's a
beautiful skin condition yeah so my
parents first found out I had XML when I
was a kid when I was actually a year old
a lot of my baby photos and baby videos
I have a lot of rashes on my face on my
neck area and it didn't take long for
them realize that it was the family dog
it was the pet dog that was causing a
lot of these irritations on my skin and
really flaring up my eczema so I found
pretty early on that was allergic to
dogs
it's also reason why I don't have a dog
now and I have this guy so and but I
don't mind being a cat guy yeah I'm
talking about you growing up with eczema
I had very low self-esteem I was very
conscious of how my skin looked in
public so I hate it going out never went
swimming
the chlorine would affect my skin going
to the beach made it even worse because
I thought salt which is natural I
thought you know going to the beach
would help my skin it really doesn't it
just irritates it and it actually stings
and makes it flare up even more I
avoided handshakes for the longest time
because one it would just hurt to give
handshakes and two I didn't want to
freak out people with the texture of my
hand it just it feels flaky it feels
rough and hard and the most painful one
of them all is
a girlfriend while having eczema I
couldn't ever open up to my girlfriends
because I didn't know how they would
receive the idea of what eczema was it's
the last thing they would ever find out
about me so when I was a kid my mom used
to take me to a lot of dermatologists to
find some sort of cure or solution a
miracle drug we tried a lot of these
things called topical steroids it's a
very quick fix but because it is a
steroid it it's a drug in which your
skin starts to feed not so much a great
fix after a week of being off of it
because it's not meant for you to use it
all the time it's gonna thin out your
skin if you use it continuously so
you're supposed to use it for flare-ups
and let me tell you after the flare-ups
are done your skin is feeling good going
through the withdrawal process of the
steroid this is one of the worst it's
worse than the x-men itself might as
well have never put on the steroid
creams to begin with I think the worst
flare-up I've ever had was in 2014 when
it just came all at once
eczema as a lot of you guys do know is
that it moves around you know it'll be
on your hands one year the next year
will be behind your legs and next year
it could be on your face and who knows
in 2014 though it was all over I was
pretty miserable but through that though
I hated myself a lot on eczema and I've
come to realize that there's not gonna
be a miracle drug that's gonna fix
everything for you recently I've
discovered a couple of different
alternative medicines that have worked
very well but still I get flare-ups
flare-ups will always happen eczema is
not a condition that you're supposed to
get rid of but it's actually a condition
in which you're supposed to find a way
to live with part of eczema is actually
stress induced and so meditation could
help a lot creating positive vibes and
getting rid of the negative ones I also
started changing my diet there's a lot
of holistic medicine behind eczema about
how you can control your diet avoid
certain foods like eggs cheese I think
for me those tomatoes too now it's
different for everyone this is what
worked for me
medicines prescribed by my dermatologist
controlling my lifestyle through
meditation diet and lastly is what you
put on top of your skin growing up my
parents struggled so hard to get me to
put
chapstick let alone lotions for my
eczema problems it didn't really even
hit me until my mid-20s when I started
realizing you know what maybe I should
put on lotion every night and having a
nightly ritual to tend to all my eczema
and that's when I started you know
experimenting with a lot of different
creams and ointments steroid free
over-the-counter stuff and a lot of
stuff that actually didn't work a lot of
the lotions I used to buy would actually
dry out my skin which is weird because
that's the exact opposite thing I'm
trying to get instead of moisturizing
and healing my skin it would educate it
more bringing out the eczema and so I've
struggled to find the right lotions my
wife TIFF was trying to help me with my
eczema problems intro so how I tried
this lotion this little ocean works
really great for me I'm like okay I'll
try it and I'll put on my face and very
next day my whole face is peeling it's
itchy it's red and I realized not eczema
people and their skin products do not
apply to me and I need a very specific
product that can work for me but
recently dove has come out the new line
called Dove Dermer series they were nice
enough to invite me out to New York to
an event to talk about eczema and eczema
awareness and they gave me the entire
lineup of their product but my favorite
though is this one tackles exactly what
I have instead of irritating my skin and
drying it out it actually moisturizes
and heals and most importantly it says
right here it's steroid free that is
music to my ears so if any you guys are
sensitive to other over-the-counter
lotions I would highly recommend dr.
burr series you know I met the team
behind it in New York they're good
people they know what they're talking
about I think they've come up with a
really nice product line for treating
skin conditions but they also have other
products for dry skin in general like
you don't have to have eczema to try
some of this stuff so if you want to
find out more about Dove Dermer series
click in the description below you'll
find the link and good luck to all the
you guys out there with XM oh I hope
your journey has a fulfilling ending I
know I don't comment very much on my
YouTube videos but feel free to comment
back on this particular video I'm more
than happy to talk about eczema and
you guys want more insider tips on how
I'm personally living with eczema feel
free to ask away
and I'll make sure to respond to as many
of your comments as possible thank you
guys
[Music]